الانتخابات النصفيه القادمه لن تكون مجردا
في خيبه ستجدد فيها نصف مقاعد الكونجرس بل
هي اختبار للديمقراطيه في الولايات
المتحده فتداعيات تشكيك رئيس الامريكي
السابق دونالد ترامب بنتائج الانتخابات
الرئاسيه الماضيه لا تزال تلقي بظلالها
على المشهد السياسي في البلاد صحيفه
واشنطنط نشرت مقاله في الموضوع اكدت من
خلاله ان الناخبين الامريكيين لا يزالون
غير متاكدين مما اذا كان بامكانهم الايمان
بالعمليه الانتخابيه الاكثر من ذلك فان
شبح التشكيك في الانتخابات واي احتمال
اعمال عنف دفع حكومه مختلفه في الولايات
المتحده الى وضع خطه استباقيه من خلال
تعزيزات من الشرطه لحمايه المباني التي
سيتم فيها فرد الاصوات
وكشفت الصحيفه تزايد الشقوق المواطنين في
عدم دقه عمليه فرز اصوات الناخبين فذلك
منذ الانتخابات الرئاسيه الاخيره وقالت
الصحيفه في استطلاع عن اجرته بشراكه مع اي
بي سي ان ثلث الاشخاص الذين تم استجوابهم
ليست لديهم ثقه في دقه عمليه الفرس
هذا ولا زالت فكره عدم الثقه في
الانتخابات تجد مروجين لها اولهم مع رئيس
الجمهوريه السابق طلال ترامب ومناصريه حيث
ابدى ترامب شكوكه بخصوص شرعيه الانتخابات
النصفيه في ولايه تنسلفانيا
لا نحن نعيد الكره مره اخرى الانتخابات
المزوره المثير في الموضوع هو ان حتى من
المرشحين هذا وحذوى ترامب في التشكيك في
النتائج المحتمله وفقا لدراسه نشرتها
نيويورك اكدت ان مواقف عدد من الجمهوريين
الذين يترشحون في ولايات رئيسيه مثل
الولايات تشكك من الان في نزاهه عمليه
التصوير وهو ما قد يضر بالعمليه ديمقراطيه
كما ترى الصحيح
وفي ارتباطن بولايه فينسربينيا فان
الانظار ستكون مركزه عليها بشكل كبير خلال
الانتخابات المقبله بالنظر الى الخصوصيه
التي تحظى بها وما يؤكد ذلك هو قيام ثلاثه
رؤساء بالمشاركه في الحملات الانتخابيه
للولايه في اليوم الاخير قبل الانتخابات
واجتمع الرئيس الحالي وبايدر مع سلفه
باراك اوباما وكلاهما الديمقراطي في تجمع
الانتخابي في الولايه في المقابل شركه
ترامب في تجمع لصالح الحزب الجمهوري
والصراع المحتدم
ياتي لكونها قادره على تحديد من سيتحكم
بالمجلس الشيوخ الامريكي الذي تتعادل فيه
المقاعد حاليا ب 50 مقعدا لكلاء الحزبين
الديمقراطي والجمهور